hallo mein name ist luca meine damen und
herren ist seht es bereits im titel
eingeblendet wir machen heute eine
challenge
besser hätte ich es nicht formulieren
können
das hier ist das erste logo was für
eingeblendet sehen wir haben jetzt hier
auf der einen seite den fake und auf der
andern seite des original oder hier das
original und da den fake also ich denke
können alle sagen das ist das instagram
logo ist am hier und läuft unsere zeit
ab das heißt ich würde sagen dass hier
safe original ich meine
der punkt ist ja nicht da vorne bei dem
logo mal schauen was das video jetzt
hier sagt also die zeit ist abgelaufen
und das richtige logo von instagram ist
das hier
ich habe richtig erraten
freunde wir machen jetzt die challenge
zusammen allerdings funktioniert diese
challenge nur wenn ihr wirklich live
wird dabei mit rat und euch nicht das
ganze video anschaut und dann habt ihr
natürlich alles richtig keit einfach
während des videos 1 kommentar wie
beispielsweise bei instagram safe links
und dann seht ihr ja selbst ob er
richtig oder falsch
und jetzt machen wir weiter mit dem
nächsten logo das nächste logo ist rolex
da würde ich sagen das linke projekt hat
er nicht so eine komische krone also ich
würde eigentlich sagen dass linke die
schrift da unterscheidet sich nicht so
deutlich von einander also das ist
eigentlich genau die gleiche schrift hat
und jetzt schauen wir mal freunde die
zeit ist jetzt abgelaufen und
stalking guten händen
nein das nächste logo freunde lg safe
rechts gekommen
als wenn das gesicht so aussieht zeit
läuft auch hier wieder ab meine damen
und herren ich bin gespannt ist wirklich
das rechte logo hier richtig freunde ich
sehe ich schon dem fall ja dadurch
freunde es wird natürlich noch
schwieriger logo nummer 14 die nase
als wenn
neben senf streifen da drin haben also
ich würde es afe sagen dass linke logo
meine damen und herren wir phasen haben
wir schauen ob der dings haken hier oben
hin kommt und wie sehen
new logo nummer 13 micro sie keine
ahnung
überhaupt keine ahnung ich würde
allerdings trotzdem sagen dass rechte
logo weil das rot oben links sieht schon
so ein bisschen vom jahr sieht auf jeden
fall für millionär aus shell meine damen
und herren an bord
ich meine das rechte und hier steht dann
schnell drin also dass wir vorne sieht
also ein bisschen komisch aus mit diesem
streifen die da unten raus gehen
deswegen würde ich eigentlich sagen
selbst dass rechte stell dich mein tag
ich halt auch relativ häufig oder bisher
alles richtig logo nummer 11 freunde ist
das playstation logo daher bin ich mir
gerade gar nicht mal so krass ich ja
also klar dass rote p das hat jetzt auch
noch sagen können und wie die
playstation front ist aber freunde ich
habe echt überhaupt kein plan ich glaube
dass rechte weil gelb und rot meine ich
mehr zusammenpassen würden also freunde
wir warten ab und richtig ist das logo
auf der rechten seite alter schwede mann
ich habe bisher alles richtig wenn ich
am ende des videos alles richtig haben
werde
freunde dann werde ich hier vor euren
augen handstand performance was logo
nummer 10 ist mobil
das ist safe das rechte ich weiß nicht
genau was mobil ist ob das eine
tankstelle ist glaube ich
gehen wir mal müssen wir da vor genau
das rechte haben wir auch hier richtig
logo nummer 9 google i/o als wenn es so
aussieht man googles safe das linke
das ist so easy das habe ich schon so
oft auf james benutzt kann ich direkt
sagen also logo auch save das linke
genau hier sehen wir auch den haken
eingeblendet logo nummer 8 haben wir
hier die links ich habe einen sweater
von denen aber ich finde schon krass
dass das lcds die logo weil sowas mit
dabei ist wo google ist und so war es
alles mögliche weil es ist ja eigentlich
nur eine band und ihr logo also safe
links auch hier wieder richtig dann
haben wir jetzt logo nummer 7 gibt
m
wo ist der unterschied also der
unterschied liegt darin dass jeder fan
nicht groß ist und hier ist das a groß
ich würde sagen das rechte
oder das ist diesmal ist schwierig ich
habe es irgendwie unterschiede aus an
dieser kugel hier gesucht aber ich würde
sagen dass rechte weil sich ja irgendwie
besser aus mit dem w hier und dem hier
oben also ich hoffe dass der hack jetzt
einfach auf die rechte seite in kom kom
kom
alter schwede magnus domino's pizza
altherr kommen freunde wie soll ich das
denn jetzt schaffen ich habe überhaupt
keine ahnung ich habe da auch meine
pizza gegessen ich würde allerdings
sagen dass rechte weil er hier ein punkt
ist hier zwei und weil das sie an so
einer reihenfolge ist wo es eigentlich
mehr sinn macht das auf der linken seite
der null sinn ich meine versteht ihr was
ich meine
normalerweise schreibt man und liest man
die chp kemal von links nach rechts in
unserer westlichen welt sage ich mal um
deswegen habe ich halt gedacht 12 aber
freunde jetzt werdet ihr leider keinen
handstand von mir sehen logo nummer 5
ist katy ich weiß noch nicht wo hier
jetzt der große unterschied ist
wo soll denn
wussten hier in unterschied also der
unterschied ist glaube ich diese
streifen hier vorne und da würde ich
sagen dass linke weil drei streifen
sollen glaube ich für kentucky fried
chicken stehen also für k s sie und das
rechte mit den vier streit sich ein
bisschen komisch aus genau freunde haben
wir auch hier wieder schönen haken
abgesahnt logo nummer vier haben es am
start uncle ben's obwohl
ist die schleife grün und hier ist die
rot also safe das wo die schleife rote
ist auf den ersten blick denke ich mir
gerade so die ganze zeit ja das sind
alles logos oder marken die ich nicht so
viel konsumieren logos mit denen ich
nicht so häufig das zu tun habe aber bei
anke bands auf den zweiten blick
natürlich die schleife ist gut
was
die ziemlich fern
die schleife ist doch safe road ein paar
sekunden später
ja okay also das ist das zweite logo was
wir bisher falsch haben
bmw-chef das linke safe ich bin zwar
noch nie im bmwi ja okay ich bin beim
mini gefahren aber der ist ja von bmw
quasi auf jeden fall ganz ganz safe das
linke logo freunde da kann ich hier
direkt weiter ein bisschen vorspulen
das ist safe safe sonst verbrenne ich
meine hand guckt da ist richtig logo
nummer 2 haben wir nestle würde ich
sagen wo liegt denn da der unterschied
wieder drin sehe ich jetzt auch nicht so
genau hier sind zwei vögel trainierten
drei vögel drin ich würde sagen dass mit
den zwei vögel nester auch ein konzern
der dauerhaft sehr krassen der kritik
ist wegen ihren methoden aber das erste
logo ist auf jeden fall richtig und logo
nummer eins vw as safe das hier
safe
die oder
oder ich würde sagen safe das rechte
logo deutsches unternehmen genauso wie
bmw ganz klar genau haben wir das rechte
logo und freunde von 17 logos habe ich
15 richtig erraten allerdings meine
damen und herren war dieses video jetzt
auch schon ein wenig älter und es gibt
ja auch schon neue unternehmen in den
letzten monaten und jahren so ein
bisschen mehr auf geblockt sind deswegen
würde ich sagen machen wir noch eine
zweite can you correctly identität eines
corporate blogs quelle nicht vergessen
die schrift fällt aus meine damen und
herren das erste logo ist spotify da
würde ich das untere safe die drei
schleifen die sie ja klar nächstes logo
nescafé wir hatten ja vorhin schon
nestlé hier haben wir tatsächlich nur
sieben sekunden zeit ich weiß nicht mal
wurde der unterschied ist ich würde
sagen das obere genau wegen dem streifen
was er genau so bei nestlé ist nächstes
logo haben wir hier pepsi das recht
linke linke safe die würden ja nicht rot
blau blau machen haben sie anscheinend
doch gemacht volkswagen hat man ja
gerade schon drin also diesmal wieder
das linke hier vorne genau sehen wir
auch jetzt das ist auch diesmal richtig
ist im nächstes logo estrella keine
ahnung was estrella ist ich würde mal so
von der ästhetik sagen dass linke genau
sehen wir auch das ist jetzt hier
richtig ist ich glaube dass es
irgendeine biermarke oder so knorr safe
links ist knorrig auch ein deutsches
unternehmen goldgas eigentlich dass es
dann hier in beiden englischen
amerikanischen videos so verbreitet ist
sneakers safe das obere die haben nicht
den ersten buchstaben so komisch rote
und weisse sneakers haben wir auch das
obere logo richtig dann machen wir jetzt
direkt weiter mit dem nächsten bmw das
hatten wir auch schon das recht auf
jeden fall sehen wir auch hier das
rechte richtig ist nasty keine ahnung
was mir die ganze nächste produkte haben
aber ich denke mal dass linke weil das
blatt nach rechts geht und es ein
bisschen sinnvoller genau haben wir auch
hier lässt das logo richtige nestlé
kommen das obere diesmal auch wieder
burger kenne meine damen und herren
würde ich sagen dass rechte weil ich
glaube dass kennt ja das logo kennt
jeder dass es überall irgendwie egal wo
man herr fährt mit dem auto sieht wenn
er dieses burger king logo dann haben
jetzt nutella das untere liga das ist
das ist schon recht easynote eller auch
hier richtig erraten
das nächste logo was wir haben mit
jaguar das ist das obere
safe
da läuft allerdings gerade nicht mal
eine zeit ab
und das ist auch das untere was kannst
du taco bell haben wir meine ich nicht
in deutschland würde ich allerdings
sagen dass linke logo weil dieser
komischen streifen hier vorne mit dem
ping keine ahnung also taco bell ist
auch das linke logo immer mal ein
bisschen for oral b das obere deck als
der striche unten sieht bisschen komisch
aus oral b hatten wir falsch das ist
unter reloe gewesen
dann haben wir hier android logo keine
ahnung ich nutze kein android ich würde
allerdings sagen dass rechts jetzt
average aber es ist glaube ich ein
amerikanisches
telekommunikationsunternehmen das untere
es richtig dass oberes riecht das
natürlich auch wieder sehr gut von den
luca dann haben wir hier chapron keine
ahnung was das sein soll linkes logo
würde ich mal sagen aber auch dass
rechte hier bin ich auf jeden fall hart
ansprechen unternehmen nicht kenne
microsoft safe das obere das hatten wir
auch vorhin schon mit dem roten da vorne
also microsoft safe richtig amazon das
untere also sonst wäre der das seti hier
oben gebogen das wird ja sonst gar
keinen sinn machen einmal zu hat auch
das untere gewonnen und das war's ich
bin gut an der stelle mich das video ist
allerdings auch beenden meine damen und
herren wenn euch solche rätsel sage ich
mal gefallen dann lass mal ein leichter
und bei 40.000 leicht freunde werde ich
nächste woche ein weiteres solcher so
einer rätsel hochladen ja grüne sonst
würde ich jetzt einfach nur noch sagen